j'ai des photos de toi regarde déjà
booba regarde t il on pas après tout ça
c'était là c'est là on va voir on va
devoir avant ta carrière solo et en duo
avec kddi du groupe l'une à titre
regarde ouais ben c'est un délire des
jeux metroid ouais ouais je pensais
apprendre à tes débuts quand tu
commences la muscu ah oui c'est vrai dit
ouais après tu as le moment tu tu
assumes complètement non s'est fait
[ __ ] par un [ __ ] de photographes ils
m'ont dit que la réal jamais ça sort
dans sa ferme et deux ans n'a jamais
rien passé fleury mais s'évaluer
s'évader disent ah là là là on doit à
ses choix elle est bonne celle là et
enfin bravo c'est quoi ça c'est là bas
voilà ces cellules sont voulus père moi
moi je savais même pas